hi and welcome to episode number 36 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am Franciscan boy and I'm here with my
colleague mark modèle hey Mark how are
you doing I'm good thanks for incest k
are you doing I'm very happy we're
interviewing someone from our team can
out again again yeah we're gonna be
interviewing Carter Morgan yeah I got a
Morgan about cabrona DS 1 dot 3 yeah
which is a really really cool release
yeah there's a lot of really new things
everything is better and faster and
bigger and he's gonna be telling us all
about it yeah and then at the end we'll
have a question of the week which is
guess what communities yes and we have a
cooper Nerys so basically it is hey so i
have google container engine and i have
like I peas that are ephemeral I want
them to be static how do I do that yes
so you will learn that at the end of the
episode absolutely but before that we're
gonna start with the cool things of the
week yeah we have a lot of GA
announcements yeah so nothing really new
there are three products that used to be
beta and now there are GA so you should
if you were not very sure you're kind of
hesitant about it now they're completely
ready for you so the first one is big
table and we discussed this with our
episode with pollination and also then
we had the episode with Ian yep talking
about big table what it is and basically
it is an incredibly fast and efficient
non-relational database I could put it
like that that works yeah so it is for
big data for big data yeah there you go
so it's basically if you have like a
huge amount of data and you need to make
sure that you know like you have really
really fast axis big table is for you
absolutely the second one is a class to
the end yeah so if you want to have edge
caching for assets that are coming out
of compute engine VMs you said caching
instead of cashing thank you yeah you
actually said it with American accent oh
that's really funny on my
can accent well yeah so if you want
cloud casing for VMS that I come out of
compute engine cloud CDN is a great way
to do it it's basically a check box
solution so that you when you put an
HTTPS load balancer in front of your VMs
you can enable cloud casing and use HTTP
headers to indicate whether I don't
should be cached or not and you can
actually kick them out the keishon it's
really really powerful then the my
favorite thing is that is incredibly
used incredibly easy to set up basically
we have an HTTPS a lot dancer then you
get there you click on check box and
boom you're done yeah yeah so that's
that's really cool and the last one I'm
gonna let you explain it I'm not a
network engineer by NMR I am also not a
network engineer but cloud router is
also gone general availability basically
that's for if you have both a non prim
and a Google cloud platform network and
you want to route traffic between the
two of them cloud router is a way of
allowing you do that integrates with our
cloud VPN system and lets you route
traffic between your own Prem and cloud
infrastructure cool and as always we'll
have a link from the show notes to every
single one of those products in case
you're interested I'm not knowing more
about it cool I think it is time to go
talk with our friend Carter yeah there
should be lots of fun let's do it this
morning we are joined by Carter Morgan
developer programs engineer for Google
cloud platform how are you doing today
Carter doing well excited to be here
excellent thank you so much for coming
down today having a chat with us about
Cooper Nettie's pretty excited but why
don't you tell us a little bit about
what you do at Google and your history
and all that sort of good stuff ok
Google I'm a developer programs engineer
on cloud platform team and I've been
focusing mostly on Cooper Nettie's I've
gotten to make a course on basic
scalable microservices with crew
Nettie's with kelsey heights are giving
a talk at i/o on best practices for
orchestrating the cloud and basically
just trying to make it easy to get
people to use communities what are the
pain points how do I make it easier cool
so I think it might be no it's not the
first time that we have a DP at the Vela
/ pro mountaineer but could you explain
for you at least what is to be a
developer of prompts engineer like
one sentence just one is like a discount
you can maybe use you it's fine you can
just ashes my job is to be customer zero
so try things out find out what the pain
points are and then make those disappear
cool one sentence damn that was good
that was good that was very good cool so
one of the reasons we have you here is
because you're awesome the second one is
a Gerber Nettie's 13 what can you tell
us about it is the latest version the
latest version in Coombe rallies math 3
is twice as big as two obviously that
sounds great uh before we get too far
into that case people haven't gone to
previous episodes on communities yes do
you want to just give us like a very
high level overview of what communities
is like how does it work what is it what
problem is it trying so crew benetti's
is a container automation framework
based on 15 years of how google rank
containers internally so it's all open
source now owned by the CNC f and what
that means is basically you can set a
desired state committees are pick up on
that for you and drive your current
state towards it so instead of having to
say manually run to a command line and
say is my application running croon a
teaser check that for you and if it's
not it's smart enough to restart it so
this frees up developers to focus on
what's really important applications I
can go more def if you want me to well I
guess is interesting you say
applications but you don't say
containers is there a reason why you do
that I think sometimes there could be a
confusion uh sometimes you might have
multiple containers that work well
together and that's your application I
might have an engine X front-end that
gives me secure routing and that's
talking to my standard application in a
talk I do or in the audacity of course
where this app that just sends hello
back so you can bundle up containers to
be your logical application so just
mention CNC f what does that mean I
always get acronyms messed up but I
think its cloud native computing
foundation I just check it out and yeah
that that it but what does that mean so
what it is is it's a it's a body that in
charge of Prometheus now which is a
monitoring app and COO benetti's and is
trying to just drive it forward and
adopt it and keep it open for everyone
to contribute so this isn't a google
owned
project communities is owned by the sea
and CF and that lets people like
Microsoft work on it red and red hat
work on it and that's what makes it so
valuable to our community nice very cool
alright so let's go back to crew
Bernie's 1.3 you're saying it's twice
the power of google a DS 1.2 why do you
say that what's it twice as big yeah
because now cuneta is 1.3 you can have
up to 2,000 notes two thousand machines
run your application in sixty thousand
containers and that's all still within
the service of SLO it which is basically
one second latency on API calls and so
in 1.2 there is 1000 so 1.3 is twice as
big is too nice so if that keeps on
growing bonded for will be four thousand
yeah I just interviewed someone and they
say well we want to see 15,000 nose and
I'm like you're not happy with 2,000 it
could be a lot of clothes especially
considering we can run 32 core instances
yeah so on top of being just bigger
assuming it's also better what are what
are the need of things what are you
excited about from governor is 103 well
I get excited about little features so
even even like little command line tools
or flags are easier so now there's coups
details set so i can just go in and say
hey I want to change my image and just
change that one command line which
running demos or just these views that's
nice but there's really big features
that are exciting like cluster
Federation initialization container is
more security features so I think it
makes sense to think about KU gratis it
says its planet scale you can run it
anywhere and you're never outgrow it and
now 1.3 we're actually really meeting
those claims with cluster Federation you
can say I want to run my I want a
cluster that's on Prem and I want a
cluster that's on gcp and that's fine
it's probably okay or if I want
something that's highly available well I
want a cluster that's in an Asian region
region and I want one that's in the u.s.
so now all that's possible so the run
anywhere thing totally you make that
happen now so let's talk a little bit
more about cluster Federation and how
that works like is this just like some
overarching sort of you know abstraction
that sits on top of communities that
makes it look the same across like
planet if I'm going cross bones or how
does that what does that really look
like okay so basically have to set up a
control playing so you set up a
federated service what this does is it
it it sets up a service for you in all
the regions that you want it makes sure
that they're healthy and then it can
route traffic to them it gives them dns
entries and all that uh you can also do
things like you know set the context and
say what region what what cluster don't
want to operate on and then you can
manage it off from one place so that's
really nice so it is kind of sitting on
top of clusters before so now you can
throw all your different clusters from
one location and that's okay and if
traffic's coming into that federated
cluster as humans intelligently routed
to like the least late and see things
like that I'm not a hundred percent sure
that what I don't want to have it from
but yeah so you have the option of
hitting the the federated endpoint in
brown robbing traffic throughout or you
can actually go to region-specific
endpoints if your application wanted you
to do that that is probably the biggest
feature i would think though is if this
release because now you know as your is
your service growers you can take it
something from on prem and say oh I want
to try this out on AWS see how that
works and you could do that or if that
doesn't work and you want to switch over
to gcp and i'm not saying i do gets
going to work anything like that um but
then you can switch it over TCP and you
don't have to take everything offline
right away you can have a gradual
rollout still be highly available still
make sure everything works before
onboarding that's one of the things I
really like about communities is kind of
the customer wins you know you can run
it anywhere so you just run around
basically looking for the best coupe
identities experience you can find in
the place that you need it and
Federation really seems to sort of fall
into that as well because I could just
gives you so much flexibility yeah it's
really really open uh if you look at
other features the rocket contain a
runtime now 1.3 that just came out and
so you're no longer forced to use docker
if another container runtime right now
rockets only one we support rocket and
docker if another container one time has
features that you need or want to rely
on you can do that now so take rocket it
a it allows you to run basically images
that are more secure with a
stripped-down OS
so you have like a vm based operating
system running your containers you can
also run on host so yeah so you have
host privileged containers running and
so if you need that kind of flexibility
and functionality now you have the
option with rocketed that's really
really cool now I've also heard of this
thing called a Nik containers mmm this
confuses me so can you explain it yeah
so basically how an initialization
containers work when you have basically
a pod and communities that's the basic
application in a pot is you know one or
more containers that know how to play
nicely together and share an IP stack
they share volumes they can talk to each
other our local host but when they start
up they started the same exact time
there is no guarantee on pod one starts
before pot too sometimes you need things
that happen in sequence before your
regular application pots start so you
wanted to pull data from github mm-hmm
well you don't want to write that into
your application that doesn't make sense
it doesn't fit the application you just
expect the data to be there when you're
a regular application containers start
so now with initialization containers
you can do that what happens is you
specify you know n number of it
initialization containers they're going
to run in order so order you list them
if any of those fail your pod is not
going to start up if they all work fine
then your pods your normal application
container father started as normal yep
so another example why this would be
useful so you have your regular
application container you know does
whatever functionality did before maybe
you want to register that with a new
service an external service for a
monitoring or health check and whatever
it might be you can put an
initialization container or
initialization step and have it register
your container without changing any of
your application code okay so is that
just so I'm clear as also that's inside
the pod it's inside the pod manifest you
write it in the in the llamo file so
commands uses a declarative syntax so
you might write down what you want the
state of it and then crew gratis are
create that state for you so in that
manifest file you're right there's a new
like initialization container section
and you right just the pod templates
okay so you have a lot more control now
in regards to the order in which these
containers come up in like one versus
and other whereas before I think I know
I've done stuff we're like I just run
retries like oh yeah first time in
photos back off like back off again back
off again now you can just be more
explicit about it right and when talking
to people a lot of people say they want
to do basically like cereal processing
so maybe there they have some kind of
pipeline going they have an application
that they want running but they need
steps one and two of the pipeline to run
well now you can do that within it
containers that's one of my I think
that's my favorite feature from
crewnecks 1.3 so I was taking I was
checking on github and I saw that the
issue called any containers it is
labeled stateful apps but what are those
whether it was a stateful app in the
coronaries world okay well a lot of
times you have applications like web
servers you can just replicate as many
as you want they don't really matter you
hear people talk about pet versus cattle
hmm so if you have a pet you care about
it if you get sick you want to fix it
you want help it you give it a name
cattle you're making hamburgers man it
doesn't really matter with that there so
what in Coober Nettie is what we have
now are pet sets and basically what this
is is a pet set manages pets and pets
have a unique name a DNS record and they
are associated with some kind of data so
if they go down we want that to come
back up we care about it we care about
the order they start at the order they
stop so that's what staple data means in
coover Nettie's so i can imagine
something of that being very useful to
run like databases and things like that
like my sequel we've replicas or exactly
so yeah there's two types of databases
that you you're going to see commonly
with this there's a the quorum type you
know like your etsy d kind of things
where you have basically need consensus
between visible no I can't even think of
the word right now multiple nodes
multiple nodes yeah that could net is
okay and then you also have something
like a like a my sequel database where
you might need to attach to one NFS disk
hmm and you're always want to be
attached to that disk or you always need
at least one pot or note attached that
disk yeah these are where stateful
applications come into play does this
also account for like where you you'll
always want something to come up in a
particular like dns entry like this
thing has to always be at this record
right so you're always gonna have the
same name because you always want to be
able to access it the same so yeah yeah
so you could put like memcache there or
other things like that as well where
where you're like I always want me to
find this in one spot
and so one of the complaints I've heard
about pet sets I've seen some really
cool demos with it I just saw a thousand
note Cassandra demo cool very cool but
one of the complaints as people said
well we could do almost all of this
before with the API and 1.2 so we've
added another object is it necessary so
it seems like it makes it a lot easier
but uh there's been a little contention
on this is the right ways it's finished
yet well pets s is still fairly filling
you so I guess there's some like their
alpha you know if you if you play with
them like things made no this is I
things I regular things make changes you
we go along so there's probably some
wiggle room there to find that the best
best case scenarios for those sort of
things right I'm just excited because
like I'm 1.2 I was writing a flashcard
app and whenever I had a pod that would
die or restart I had to go manually
detach the disc so that's fixed now
later it automatically they have
detached controllers that automatically
unattached or disc and let it reattached
when the pot starts up again so that's
aside from pet set so just stay for
applications and crew benetti's 1.3 or
better yep and I guess that also ties
back to I can get containers you're
talking about like with Stifel apps
having things come up in the right order
really is important mmm yeah the so
there's a lot of support around that pet
sets is a nice feature and I'm sure
we're gonna see a lot more in the coming
months at people using it and testing it
out see what the limits are cool so
we've covered a little bit about all the
things that you can do like more nodes
and you can also have any containers and
stay for labs and you can run rocket
instead of talker and all of those
things those are amazing there's one new
one one more thing that I saw that
Kelsey hatar had written uh it's
carbonate is the hard way could you tell
us a little bit about that yeah one
Kelsey's great like great we agree we
agree well he's just really good at it
getting in the community and listening
to what their needs are and with cooper
Nettie's what we're seeing is a lot of
people think it's really hard to get
started with Cooper Nettie's maybe the
documentation isn't quite there around
the steps to start up a cluster or maybe
there's a lot of you know there are a
lot of steps and starting a cluster so
what Cooper Nettie's the hard way is is
Kelsey just wanted to go and document
say okay here's the steps for a basic
saying default
configuration for starting up a cluster
that's it that's all it is so now you
can go and learn everything that's
involved I guess so does the pain point
before was I mean GK is easy right you
push a button you get a cluster there r
cube up scripts to firing up a cluster
but i guess that's kind of magic e quote
unquote right it abstracts away the
details so you don't know what's going
on in your system so how do you adopt a
new framework if you don't know even how
it starts up or how it stops or what are
the pieces that interoperate yeah so I
guess looking through Kelsey stuff he
actually like takes you through
step-by-step and shows you everything
that you need to do mm-hmm it's not
everything there's still a little bit
more but this is a great starting point
so now you see the community there's a
cig on a special interest group Joe Veda
and a bunch of other really really smart
people are working on okay how do we
minimize the amount of steps without
locking people and keeping Cooper
nettings as open as it is that's
fantastic action i didn't i didn't
realize that sig existed or just got
created so yeah it just got started up
within the last month I think no that's
great that's I mean that has been a
common sort of complaint point around
communities like how do i setup clusters
why's it so hard how does this stuff
work and so it's really nice to see the
reaction from the goonies community and
the authors and the people who work on
it like going okay yeah that's a problem
let's fix it right it's fun because I
mean communities is mostly her largely
community-driven when you look at the
number of commits from external people
outside of Google outside of the big
companies it's exciting and when you see
the amount of interest on slack in this
in the cigs on the gate issues it's one
of the one of the reasons why I'm really
excited about Cooper Nettie's cool so uh
this makes me think about not that long
ago actually might have been almost a
year already one of our co-workers rate
sang created a way what was the name it
was like a mini cluster yeah he told it
a mini cluster mini cluster which I
don't know if you've seen it it's like
five raspberry PI's one on top of each
other so do you think that the pain he
had to go through to make Cooper nannies
run on that ladle raspberry pi cluster
could be could be less now or house how
hard or how easy it is to get Cooper
nice cluster started outside of TKD well
there's a joke going around why
for all the people with their pie demos
that they're also running like Cooper
Nettie's 1.1 because it's too hard yeah
okay but no um the steps are now going
to document it one of the things crew
brand is the hard way by Kelsey Heights
are that documents the steps his his sig
develops and pushes they're trying to
have a short time table on it has a
developed closer more it's going to get
easier nice so I think just having
documentation that was the first step
and those are that's an area where we
can definitely improve documentation
around communities in general so
something I've seen in many demos that
get people quite impressed is when you
update from one image to something else
like migrations of Granada's are very
very nice is there anything new on that
oh yeah there's a mr. Newcombe and I
think it's qtr rollout status now so you
can actually see what's going on if
you've looked at any of my old demos I
used to run some kind of script and I
would manually do this when I was just
built right into the tool so you can see
step by step what's going on how's your
cluster scaling up hows it scaling down
so that's a really nice feature that's
cool so if I'm like changing from one
image to another inside communities I
can actually see very easily what's
what's changing yeah I've done the same
thing I've done like watch commands that
change every two seconds and done like
get pods just to see which ones are up
or not that's super super handy there's
a lot of get little features and little
commands throughout there's a new secret
so basically secrets are sensitive data
that you don't want to store in your pot
or in your image well now there's a new
one for generating TLS certs so if you
want to test something locally you can
just use QC tale crema and to create
some tests certs again it's that ease of
use that's going to make gratis the
platform to adopt I'm going to take the
opportunity to ask you pernetti's
question can sweet have you here here
okay and I'm sure I'm sure this has been
covered a bit but I it comes up a lot so
when do I use secrets and when do I use
config maps ok config maps are for
string data and they're basically like
so if I had nginx config something that
anyone could see it's not it's not a big
problem mm-hmm but it might vary between
two different runs in my container or
two different environments whether its
production in dev or whatever secrets
are your password your search or keys
and things that you don't want to hand
out so you're
is gonna want to use secrets for
information that you want to keep ok so
if I've got my database records like
where's my database what's its user name
what's his password that's a secret I
want to put that in there definitely the
password yeah I'd probably use the
username stuff like that too or an
environment variable but definitely the
password you're going to want a secret
for that absolutely and then so you have
something like it in genetics config or
something like an apache config like
whatever who cares now another thing
that's really cool is config maps you
can notify pods downstream when configs
change so if i change my engine X config
I can notify a pot downstream I don't
think you do that with secrets and I
believe you can right how does that
notification happen is that like files
change or environment variables just
change or environment variables and
that's see today is my understanding and
there's a downstream API for that ok
cool but uh yeah so what else is secrets
can also in n configs can all be passed
through environment variables configs
can also be passed command line I'm sure
and so you have a lot of flexibility
when using them so I try and tell people
to use them as much as possible you know
yeah always I was chatting with someone
about keeping their word press come fig
and whether they should put that in a
secret or a config map and I think we
ended up deciding to put it in a secret
because not only contains just basic
information about WordPress but also
like username and passwords for the
database things like that and it's
actually the wp-config.php phone the
whole thing but that was really cool
actually hadn't thought of doing stuff
like that to really just even just
configure just generally like a
wordpress install or something like that
yeah now what I want to learn next is I
learned how to use cout Nettie's and
production more is so someone actually
has to take the secret and give it to
the API certain so do you use something
like vault for that do you where do you
store that secret initially so what I
want to know yeah there's a few
different interesting tools that could
help you do that I know I used to do a
bunch of stuff I danceable and have
inbuilt encryption so you could do
ansible vault like you're talking about
yeah it's a good question excellent all
right well we're we're starting to soda
head towards the end of our time here is
there anything else you want to mention
or touch on or just plug in general
maybe if you're going to be somewhere do
something
we got anything there no I've got an
article coming out on the crew Nettie's
blog in the next few days and on the
open-source blog where we interviewed
Joseph Jack's from his Maddock Honda
he's someone that's really active in the
community so it's cool to see him say
why he chose the bed his business on
Cooper nettings why he or where he wants
Gruber netezza go in the next few months
he's a guy that set 15,000 nose makes me
think he's a crazy person and uh what he
thinks is wrong with Cooper nannies what
could be better so it's a fun interview
so I check it out great well we're not
going to say goodbye or thank you
because we're going to continue
interviewing you for next episode yes
next week we're going to have a chat
about what came in 1.3 specifically for
gke so stay tuned until next week thanks
again to Carter Morgan to span these
first episode with us telling us all
about urbanize one two three we're
looking forward to having him back next
week for more about it specifically
about Google container engine but before
we finish with the episode we had this
question of the week which is okay so
with communities it's really easy to
expose a service and when you expose the
surface basically you're creating a load
balancer and you get you get an IP now
you expose that and people start using
that IP and then you change something
you want to migrate to the new version
and you need to recreate that load
balancer how do you make it so you will
keep the same IP because that AP is
ephemeral right like yeah I don't want
to change the IP and make every single
one of my customers which is like to
yeah I don't have I don't have started
yet but how do I keep them from having
to follow with my piece changing just I
want that IP to be ephemeral yeah we
don't we don't want that DNS to be
changing dns address has been waiting
for propagation like that ever a good
idea that's no fun so it's actually
really straightforward we were looking
at a blog post that one of our teammates
Terry Brian wrote about this and it's
really quite cool so you're able to say
yep you've created that load balancer
you've got an IP address you're able to
go into your console networking look at
your external IP address
and it's pretty much there's a little
drop down that you can change from
ephemeral to static and that makes your
IP address static just great that makes
it belong to your project that means you
have it you own it it's yours what
school from that point is ok but what
happens if i delete my load balancer I
want to make sure I keep that that
static IP address for this load balancer
for the scuba nidhi service so there's a
sitting inside the y ml that you can set
it's a load balancer IP it's pretty much
exactly what you would expect it to be
and you can put in the IP address that
you wanted to have and if you are in
that IP address it will give it to you
from there you can just you know cube
CTL apply the service and that gives you
the IP address from that point forward
if you want to just delete the service
and then recreate it or maybe give it to
another service you can do that it's
pretty straightforward nice sounds like
the obvious solution just working with
yes always nice which is really nice
very intuitive ok well thank you for
joining me once again Francis for a
wonderful episode you up to anything
particularly interesting in the next few
weeks are you just kind of doing some
online content doing some other cool
stuff I'm doing some online content
working on some new videos that I've
been thinking about for a while and now
that I'm not traveling I will be working
on that so looking forward to releasing
videos and blog post and eat something
so what about you so when this comes out
I will be in Israel after that I'm
taking a short vacation off to Australia
but then i'll be at pax dev later in the
month so nice if you're gonna be there
please do say hello i'd love to say hi
san francisco to israel yeah some
australia's on the way yeah sure yeah
it's going thats cool well have safe
trips and talk to you all next week see
you next week
you